south dakota governor christie noam has
announced her state will send
national guard members to assist at the
border she joins us now from cpac where
she spoke literally just moments ago
governor welcome thank you thank you for
inviting me
the theme of your speech today was joe
biden's america for those who didn't get
to see you perform in front of that
crowd at cpac
would you lay out some of the key points
i talked about the very different world
we're living in today than the one
i had the opportunity to grow up in and
talked about the fact that we're seeing
crime lawlessness and open border
that is devastating families and
businesses and jeopardizing our national
security so i talked about that decision
to send my national guard down to the
border i was the first governor in this
country
that when texas and arizona asked for
help that decided to send national guard
troops that
know how to complete missions they're
trained for it they're equipped for it
and they're the best
so talked about that the importance of
taking this threat seriously
and also pushing back on critical race
theory at 16 19 project
because those are two ways that they
will quickly destroy
america if we don't stop them you
mentioned sending
national guardsmen to the border about
125 from south dakota do you have a
sense of
when they will leave governor and what
their role will be
i sent 50 at the request of governor
abbott
to texas originally they've already left
i sent them off a few days ago they are
currently down on the border helping
secure that
in partnership with border control
agents and local law enforcement
officers
now what's interesting to me was as soon
as i announced that i was sending
national guard troops
it was just days later that the white
house and the pentagon asked us to send
more
so another 125 requests came forward
they've since
looked for more resources as well so i
think it's interesting to me
that as soon as governors took the stand
to fight for our national security that
it appears to me that
the federal government has gotten the
message that they better do their job
because governors will step in and do it
if they don't you have a long resume you
served four terms on capitol hill
my memory is correct you also are now a
ceo
of running the state of south dakota
you're seen as a potential presidential
candidate a whole lot of buzz about you
these days
if you were in the white house right now
what more would you do to address the
crisis at our border
i'd get the resources down there to make
that it's sure that it's secure
i would i would ensure that they have
the resources to not
let illegals into this country that we
would continue to enforce our laws
without a
without laws and without a border we
aren't a country and that's what joe
biden is doing to devastate
the our future really as a free and
independent nation
so you know the biggest jobs that i've
been the most proud of
is running businesses being a mother a
wife and now a grandmother and i think
the perspective that i have
from all of those including being in
congress and now as a governor
gives us the opportunity to weigh in in
a way
that really reflects what the american
people want they want
somebody who will step up every single
day and continue to defend the country
that they love so much
your grandkids are blessed to have such
a young grandmother good for you
congratulations on that um your thoughts
as you interact with folks there at cpac
what are you hearing from
a lot of loyal conservatives
i think they are ready to continue to
push
this country to
remain independent one of personal
responsibility
one of freedoms and liberties that tells
our true and honest history
so they are optimistic they are hopeful
they are not discouraged at all they
recognize the threat we see coming out
of the white house and the federal
government
but they also recognize that
conservative values are really what
built this country
and that creates opportunity for all
people and and that's just the message
that we need to continue to carry to
everyone
not just our friends but we need to
carry it to even those
that we've disagreed with in the past to
make sure we win their hearts and minds
back to
american values you had a recent clash
with the federal government
over the fireworks show at mount
rushmore do you think that was payback
because you had president trump out
there a year ago
i do i feel it was specifically
political
and punitive there was no valid reason
to deny us the opportunity to celebrate
independence day at our national
monument that we're also proud of and
it's unfortunate i'm currently suing the
federal government over that decision
hopeful that we'll be able to return
those fireworks next year
governor christie nome of the great
state of south dakota thanks so much for
your time have fun there in dallas
thank you we will thanks so much